Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishiston Plus Visa and earn three times the points at grocery stores and restaurants as well as on gas, EV charging, daily transit, streaming services, digital gaming and more all the time. Get the RBC Ion Plus Visa. Three times the points. Conditions apply. Visit rbc.com slash ion cards. Okay Martin, let's try one. Remember, big. You got it.
The Ford It's a Big Deal event is on. How's that? Uh, a little bigger. Ahem. The Ford It's a Big Deal event. Nice. Now the offer? Lease a 2025 Escape Active all-wheel drive from 198 bi-weekly at 1.99% APR for 36 months with 27.55 down. Wow, that's like $99 a week. Yeah, it's a big deal. The Ford It's a Big Deal event. Visit your Toronto area Ford store or Ford.ca today.
Long had the snake lived in the dungeon, coiled in the black and filthy water, bloated from feasting on the Empress's prisoners. It was a colossal, greedy, pitiless thing, a creature of nightmares. Already it had sensed their presence, and even now it was rising for the kill. Its cruel head loomed from the shadows, its yellow eyes glittered with hatred, its fangs glistened with beads of poison, its forked tongue flickered with pleasure. Harold moved fast, groping among the corpses, scrabbling through the filth, his fingers found a broken piece of wood, but the monster was faster. Suddenly it was on him, its horrible coils winding around his chest, pulling him down
towards the water, squeezing the very last breaths from his lungs. So that was JRR Tolkien in his brilliant book Adventures in Time Fury of the Vikings chapter entitled The Return of the King. And obviously, Dominic, wasn't really JRR Tolkien, was it? It was you! It was an even better writer. It was an even better writer. Yeah.
And you are describing there one of the countless thrilling scenes in the epic life of Harold Hardrada, fugitive from Norway, mercenary captain for the Grand Prince of Keeve. And now he has come to the golden city of Caesar, Constantinople, and he is a recruit in the Varangian Guard. And we will be finding out how giant serpents feature in the story later on. But for now, we are in 1035 and what is going on? So we left Harold in the last episode at the point in which he is just enlisted in the Varangian Guard, this kind of special forces unit of largely Scandinavian mercenaries. Very baggy trousers.
With great silk trousers, exactly. Now, no sooner has he enlisted, Tom, the news reaches the Imperial city that Arab corsairs have sailed into the Aegean, raiding the towns of the Greek islands and carrying the men, women and children off into slavery. And so for Harold Ardrada, the adventure begins. Brilliant. Very exciting. So actually, he's now going to be on campaign for the next six or seven years. Can't be sure exactly how long, but let's say roughly six or seven years.
As that Adventures in Time book, which I recommend to our listeners, describes his life is a blur of action, racing into battle on the deck of a war galley, storming ashore on an island at dawn, scaling the walls of an enemy castle, dealing out death with a sweep of his sword. Now actually the truth is we're getting most of this from the Icelandic sagas, which as we said last time, were written down at least 200 years later by people living in a different world. I mean, living in Iceland, I couldn't really be further away from Constantinople and still be in Europe. That's right. And they're also much more obviously Christian and they are doing an awful lot
of projection. There's a lot of fictionalization, and there is a lot of use of literary formulae, which means it is very difficult for us to be certain, to have any degree of certainty about what he did. However, we have what people at the time would have called Roman sources, what we would call Byzantine sources, that give a sense of the kind of campaigns the Empire was fighting. So we can sketch out a very tentative narrative, I think. We do know that they did fight pirates in the spring of 1035. So Snorri Sturluson's saga, King Harold's saga, which is part of the cycle called Hymes Kringla, that tallies with the account of a Greek chronicler called John Skylitzes, who talks about ships from
North Africa attacking the Cyclades. So there probably was a bit of action in the Aegean. And then probably later that summer, 1035, the Varangians are sent to the far eastern borderlands of the empire, so Armenia, where the imperial army is besieging a city called Berkri on the shores of Lake Van. Now this is a world that is very kind of fragmented and confusing because the Abbasid Caliphate is largely broken up and there's all kinds of rival emirates across the Middle East, kind of Arab, Turkic, Kurdish and so on. So it's sort of all very confusing. The Roman army is besieging this city. The Vikings normally hate sieges. They're no good at them.
They don't really enjoy them because they don't obviously have many towns and castles in Scandinavia, so sieges aren't really their thing. But this one goes very well. And the sagas say, oh, that's Harold. Harold's just a brilliant man and he's responsible. But in reality, the overall commander who plays a bit of a part in Harold's story was a Greek general called George Maniakes. He was another giant like Harold Hardrada. So Harold Hardrada, I think we established in the last episode, was he seven and a half feet tall? Seven and a half feet, yes. Maniakes, I'm going to read you the description by the monk and courtier Michael Psellas.
Michael Psellas said, Maniakes was a Rothfou man, 49 feet tall and possessed of a violent temper, a fiery whirlwind with a voice of thunder and hands strong enough to make walls totter and shake gates of brass. He had the quick movement of a lion and the scowl on his face was terrible to behold. But Michael Sellers says that all basically all Verangians are, I mean, at least nine, 10 feet tall. Yeah. You sometimes you just have to trust the sources, don't you? You do.
An air of skepticism. You could carry skepticism too far. Well, there's kind of hint of Samson there, I think tall. Yeah. Sometimes you just have to trust the sources, don't you? You do. An air of skepticism. You could carry skepticism too far. Well, there's kind of hint of Samson there, I think, in his description. They're shaking the gates of brass, making walls totter, exactly. So Maniarches and Harold didn't get on at all. And the sagas say the Varangians demanded that Harold be put in command, said this Maniarches has got to go, but actually Maniarches had Harold record to Constantinople, but that worked out well for him because if this story is even remotely accurate,
he then got sent on a very exciting expedition. So we do know that the emperor had concluded a deal with the Fatimids in Egypt to rebuild the church of the Holy Sepulchre in Jerusalem, which had been semi-destroyed by a mad caliph in 1009. So Al-Hakim, who features in my thrilling vampire novel, The Sleeper in the Sands. Really? Yeah.
Is he a vampire? No, Al-Hakim isn't. But vampires are present. Vampires are definitely present. But also Dominic, just to say that the destruction of the Church of the Holy Sepulcher, which had been built by Constantine and was pretty, you know, I mean, it's, it's the great focus of Christian devotion. It has a massive impact, not just on Byzantium, but on Latin Christendom. And the news of it going back to Latin Christendom stirs up all kinds of millennial anxiety. So it's part of this
kind of swirl of apocalyptic dread that in the long run will feed into the first crusade. So Urban II, when he does his great sermon kind of summoning the first crusade, he makes mention of exactly this, the destruction of the Church of the Holy Sepulcher. And it may not surprise Jewish listeners to discover who a lot of Christians in Latin Christendom blamed for this. And it wasn't Al Hakeem. Oh really? So this gives rise to a lot of pogroms and stuff. It gives rise to one of the first kind of big outbreaks of antisemitic violence in Latin Christendom. Yeah. So it really reverberates.
Right. So anyway, the emperor has concluded this deal to go and rebuild it. And he sends a team of architects and carpenters and stuff and bishops and monks and Roman bigwigs who want to go and see the church and a Varangian escort was sent with them and the sagas say Harold was one of them. Jerusalem is a bit of a building site when they get there, if he does genuinely go. It had been very badly smashed up by this mad caliph and by the Fatimids generally, but there'd also been a series of earthquakes in the 1030s. So if they got there, a lot of the stuff was in ruins. The sagas say that Harold is there as part of this escort and he, and I quote, generously
gave donations so much gold that no one knows the amount. The sagas also say he'd left all his gold in Constantinople before he left, so those things can't both be true. And given that he's saving all this money, in his saver account, I think it's highly unlikely that he travelled with enormous quantities of gold. Snorri Sturluson in King Harald's saga says, Harald went to the Jordan and bathed in the water in the manner of all pilgrims. Might be true, mightn't it? Yeah, and there's absolutely no reason to believe that wouldn't be true.
That's exactly what he would do. But his longest posting, so probably after this was to Sicily. And this seems to have been from about 1038 to 1041. And Sicily, of course, as you will note Tom, is the, one of the great strategic prizes in the Mediterranean. And we did the series about Carthage versus Rome. Remember you were taking it through all the battles there. I mean, basically that hasn't changed at all.
Sicily is very fertile. It's very rich. It's perfectly placed. It's been under Islamic rule for what? 140 years, something like that. The Kalbid emirs who are based in Palermo and they're the people who introduced oranges, lemons, sugar, silk silk and all sorts of exciting irrigation systems. We do love an irrigation system on the rest of history, do we not?
Oh, I love it. I love it. I mean, history is basically the story of irrigation systems, isn't it? In a very real sense, yes. Yes. So the Roman army landed probably about 10,000 troops under George Maniachis, nine feet tall. Must have been very displeased to see Harold Hartrath. Yeah, I know.
Now this is where the sagas really get stuck in. They have some great fun with all this. So to give you a sense of the sort of stories they tell, we've got bird action. So Harold gets the Varangians to collect birds. They fix bits of burning sulfur to their feet and send them out over the town. You know, they land on all the thatched roofs, the igneous have been flamed. The slight drawback with this story is that it's been told about every commander in history.
Well, but more specifically, Dominic, it's been told about St Olga. Of Kiev. Of Kiev, who's the grandmother of Vladimir. And she was the very first Kievan ruler to be baptised. Right. And she played exactly that trick, didn't she, on, I think it was the very first Kievan ruler to be baptized. Right. And she played exactly that trick, didn't she? Oh, and I think it was the Drevlians. It was, it was the Drevlians.
So I think you can see a certain influence there, I would say. Well, hold on. You could say, therefore the story is clearly made up. This is just the old group of Kiev story. Or you could say he's been influenced because he's been in Kiev and he's picked up these important military techniques involving birds. You could say that. Then there's tunnel drama.
So this is outside a town near Mount Etna and the sagas, which always paint maniocs with his nine feet of flesh as an absolute fool. He says, oh, this, we can never take this town. And Harold says, no, if you allow me the loot when I get in, I should show you. And he and the Varangians dig a tunnel all the way from a nearby ravine. They burst out of the tunnel into the great hall of the defenders while they're having a feast. Who would have thought it? Slaughter them all, throw up in the gates. That was good killing that day. And my favorite one is the coffin ploy.
Oh, this is brilliant. This is the Syracuse one. This is in Syracuse. So they can't take this town. The Romans don't know how to take this town. He says, I've got a brilliant wheeze. They spread the word. Harold is very seriously ill. Then the word spreads. He's dead. And the Varangians send messengers into the city where there are Christian churches as well as mosques. And they say, look, we'd love to give a church funeral. I know we've been besieging you, but would it be okay if we came in? And the local churchmen, very kindly people say, oh, yes, okay. As long as you, you can only bring 12 men in to bury this guy.
But Tom, it was astounding to know this is all a cunning trick. And actually Harold, Harold is not dead. He's one of the 12 pallbearers and they're all slightly implausibly wearing armor and carrying swords under their silk morning clothes and they're all 12 foot. Yeah. So at this point, actually his, his great friends in the Varangians, they're also part of the pallbearers and these are two splendid men called Ulf and Haldor. They're both from Iceland.
They are described as men of exceeding strength and superb warriors. And the amazing thing is the three of them map perfectly onto Aragorn, Legolas and Gimli from the Lord of the Rings. So Ulf, we are told, a man of great understanding, clever in conversation, active and brave and with all true and sincere. So he's clearly Legolas. Whereas Haldor, very stout and strong, he was not a man of many words, but short in conversation, told his opinion bluntly and was obstinate and hard.
So he's Gimli. Yeah, he's a dwarf. So Dominic, so they're both from Iceland. Do you think that this makes the story less or more plausible? So in other words, is Snorri Stelarson kind of making it up and making them be Iceland because he's an Icelander or is it preserving authentic memories handed down by the people of Iceland? There's no doubt in my mind that this is preserving authentic memories that have never been embellished
and are scrupulously accurate. So the story that follows is true. They get inside the gatehouse with this coffin and then apparently they drop the coffin, they blow a trumpet, the coffin blocks the gate. So then the rest of the army can pile in after them. There's incredibly fierce fighting. All three of them are wounded.
Harold's standard bearer is killed. And Harold says to Haldor, pick up the standard, pick up the standard. But Haldor is fighting off a dozen men at that point. And he says to his, to Harold, let the devil carry the standard for you, you coward. And Harold, do you want to do Harold's laugh? He gives a great belly laugh, doesn't he? He does. You are talkative today, Haldder, but fearless all the same.
And then he smacks off another head with his axe. This is exactly what happened. I'm afraid I might have broken the microphone with that mighty laugh. Yeah, I think you've broken the sound barrier with that. So now the sagas say that as a result of all these wheezes, they managed to take Sicily and people can gauge the accuracy of the sagas by the fact that in fact, Sicily was never taken and the Romans ended up with just a pitiful foothold in the Northeast. And actually Sicily didn't, here's the irony, Sicily didn't fall till the end of the century and it fell to the Normans.
Because it does fall to people of Scandinavian descent. Yeah, but not these guys. So we've been talking about this in our previous series about the Normans adventurers who've been going to the south of Italy at the beginning of the 11th century and building their castles there, employing their armor, their horses in the way, kind of predatory manner. And they start looking at Sicily. And amazingly, they launch an invasion. And there is another famous bird related story in this. So
in 1066, Roger de Oudveld, the great, who will become the ruler of Sicily, he defeats a Muslim army and the Muslims have brought along carrier pigeons. And Roger takes these carrier pigeons and he orders the paper that they've been carrying to be dipped in the blood of the Muslim dead, given back to the carrier pigeons, who then fly back to Palermo with news of the great Muslim defeat and the Normans then capture Palermo. Wow. So there's a lot of bird related action in this episode.
People of Scandinavian descent interfering with birds for military purposes. Yes, it's the theme. So they don't take Sicily, but everyone says that Harold has done brilliantly. And when he gets back to Constantinople, he is, we are told, promoted to an elite bodyguard of the emperor. Manglovites is his name, he has a special golden sword. And then the emperor, Michael IV, who you may remember from the previous episode, was the Emperor's toy boy, who has basically strangled his predecessor to become emperor. He's going off to fight the Bulgars in 1040.
And we know, we really do know that he takes Harold Hardrada with him, because serving alongside them was a soldier called Cacauamanos who later wrote a military manual and in this manual he wrote, Araltes campaigned with the emperor and performed great deeds of valor against the enemy as was fitting for one of his noble race and personal ability, Araltes Harold. And it's fascinating because that suggests that there are people in Constantinople now who are aware of Harold's noble descent.
So though I think they see the manual is probably written after he's become king. So after he has spoiler alert after he's returned to Norway. Anyway they they smashed the Bulgarians. They capture the Bulgarian king, the cut off his nose, the gouged out his eyes. They let him back in chains to Constantinople. And Cacumanus says that the emperor rewarded Oraltes for his valour and gave him the title of Spathorokandidatos, which is a court rank, not a military one. So a kind of rank at court, very prestigious for any foreigner, let alone a barbarian from the wilds of the north. So he now gets an even fancier sword and he
gets a special golden torc called the Maniacion which he gets to wear. It's a bit like the Ottomans giving Nelson that massive great jewel. Yeah, and Harold's only 25 at this point. So he's clearly made a name for himself and he's done extremely well and it's all very exciting. But now this is where the sort of Game of Thrones side replaces the Lord of the Rings. So the Emperor Michael, he's Michael the fourth, he's called Michael the Paphlagonian, he's from the Black Sea coast of Anatolia. And his brother John, who was the eunuch kind of Lord Chamberlain, had got him a job at the court. He's got all his brothers a job, hasn't he? And basically all his cousins and stuff.
So there's one called Anthony the Fat. He becomes the Bishop of Nicomedia, thanks to John's string pulling. And John is essentially the kind of prime minister, isn't he? He is. He's um... Little finger. Little finger or Varys. He's a eunuch, so he's Lord Varys.
From Game of Thrones. So this guy, Michael, he had seduced Zoe, he'd possibly murdered her husband in his bath. He's now been emperor for six years. He's in his late twenties. Michael Sellas says he was as fresh as a blossom, bright-eyed and apple-cheeked. Nice. So that's nice. Unfortunately, Michael's good looks are starting to curdle because he's always suffered from epilepsy and it's getting much worse. And when he has fits,
this is hidden from visitors to the court behind a series of elaborate curtains, which can be deployed at any moment. But he's now suffering from edema, dropsy, which means that his body is being grotesquely swollen with fluid. And by late 1041, it's pretty obvious that he's dying of this. There's no cure. They don't know what to do. Although I spoke, they could try and drain him, but that doesn't work. Now, John, the eunuch says to him, look, you're going to have to name a successor.
And ideally from our family, because we want to stay on top. And as luck would have it, they have another Michael, who is their sister's son. It's brilliant isn't it, how everyone is called Michael. Got loads of Michaels. Or Harold. He says, why don't you adopt this Michael. You and Zoe adopt him as your son. He'll be named Caesar and we'll put him in a townhouse in the suburbs and you know, he
can hang around and when you die, he'll come in as Michael the fifth. So we come to the 10th of December, 1041, Michael the fourth is bloated, he's swollen, fluid everywhere, shambles. So his loving days are over. His loving days are over. He's taken to the monastery of St. Cosmas and St. Damien and there he's given holy orders.
Actually, it's not just kind of confession. He's given holy orders. He's tonsured like a monk and then he dies. Meanwhile, Michael the fifth, he's brought to the palace. It's really smooth succession. It works perfectly. So everything looks great. However, there is a twist.
So we'd mentioned only in passing Zoe. Zoe is now in her late fifties. She is the one person in the palace who has the blood of the Macedonian dynasty. I kind of imagine her as looking like Diana Dores. Yes, who would she be played by now? She's quite sort of... Blousy. I was going to say blousy. Well, I can tell you what Michael Sellers says. Zoe was well-rounded, though not very tall. She had hair of gold and her entire body
glowed with the paleness of her skin. There was little sign of her age. In fact, if you noticed the perfect proportions of her limbs and did not know her, you would have thought she was a young woman, for her skin was unwrinkled, glossy and smooth, with no lines anywhere. I think it's fair to say Michael said this is slightly objectifying, Zoe. He is, isn't he? He's behaved poorly, he's let himself down. Or he's paying compliment to the power of the unguent merchants of Constantinople. He is, because she let us we'd established last time she loves a
potion or cream. So hence wrinkle free. Wrinkle free, ointments just basically massively into ointments. She is, Michael Seller says a woman of passionate desires prepared equally for life or death. Now she had placed a bet on Michael the fourth and actually that had gone horribly wrong because once he'd, I mean you say his loving days were over when he became sworn with Dropsy, but actually his loving days had ceased before that because as soon as he became emperor
he basically locked her in the women's quarters and said, I've had enough of you, don't come out. So now she's back and she's got this Michael V who's her adoptive son. Do things work out better with Michael the fifth? They do not. He is determined to have a break with his predecessor and bring in all his own people, Scythian eunuchs. So these are kind of, these may well be Slavs or Pechenegs and he'd get rid of the old guards.
But the person he really hates with an absolute passion is Zoe. What Michael Sellers says once he had addressed her as mistress, but now the very idea made him want to bite off his own tongue and spit it away and discuss. So we'll put him down as undecided. Yeah, he's not a fan. And he waits for a few months till Easter 1042 and then he makes his move. So on Easter Sunday, these Scythian eunuchs burst into her chamber and they drag her out and they drag her before him. And he says, you, I know you've been trying to poison me.
You know, you're clearly as guilty as hell. You're going to be sent off to the Prince's islands and the sea of Marmara, just off Constantinople. And you'll be sent to a nunnery. Get thee to a nunnery. I mean, literally. So very reminiscent of what's going to happen to Edith a few years later when Edward the Confessor packs her off to a nunnery. I mean, nunneries are obviously
very useful if you want to get, you know, an unwanted queen. Exactly. So we're told she was immediately put on a ship along with certain men who were given free hand to insult her. She's stripped of her purple robes and her head was shaved and I quote, as though she was a common whore. That's very harsh. Very harsh. And I imagine her hair.
Golden hair. Golden hair and much treated again with all kind of ointments and salves and permades. And now casually thrown aside, very poor. Now Michael has clearly made a massive miscalculation here because Michael Sellers, the chronicler who knows a lot about kind of court politics says, you know, everyone despised him. He was regarded as a slave to his emotions, erratic and all this. And Zoe was very popular in the city. So she has been the most glamorous person in the life of Constantinople since she was basically born in 978. She'd been born in the purple, her father was
an emperor, her uncle was an emperor, her grandfather was an emperor. She's part of the furniture and she's a great favorite of the crowds. So on Easter Monday, the next day, the word spreads to the city. Everyone was worried about the empress. Deep down men knew matters had got out of hand and they were not afraid to speak up about it, says Michael Sellers. The Emperor, Michael V, he sends the city's prefect to read out a statement in the in the forum to explain what he's done and the crowd go absolutely berserk, smashing everything up, rioting and whatnot. They end up breaking into the cathedral, Hagia Sophia, they get the patriarch to start ringing the bells, they browse the city. There's general sort of chaos and fighting and looting and stuff.
There's actually a fragment in the sagas by a guy called Valgaard who was a guardsman, a Varangian guard from Iceland who ended up becoming a Scalded poet who says, "'The flames licked the stones, crackling embers shot from the soot and columns of smoke rose vertically from the tumbling houses. You see, I think that's brilliant. And I was saying earlier how I prefer kind of blank verse to rhyming verse when it's Vikings. Also Dominic, just to say about the patriarch, Alexios, that John the eunuch, the Varys of Constantinople, he had tried to get rid of him and replace him.
And there's all kinds of weird political currents that we can only vaguely glimpse, I think, that are going on, including the Varangians. So the Varangians, their loyalty is pledged to the imperial family. They are mercenaries working for the imperial family. And I think it's a fair assumption that they feel very put out about the arrival of these Scythian eunuchs. The Pechenegs. And there's some form of power struggle, I think, between the two of them. And my guess is that they are probably in on this riot. And it's all been planned and it's actually a little bit
more of a counter-coup than it is really a riot. Anyway, by the Monday afternoon, it's become a massive street battle. It's Michael and his Scythians against the mob and the Varangians. And on the Tuesday, I mean, this would be a superb kind of HBO series or something. Cause on Tuesday, the attackers break into the palace, partly through the emperor's box in the Hippodrome, which has a tunnel leading through to the, to the palace or corridor. They kind of fight their way into the Imperial quarters. And guess what?
Michael has escaped. He's gone off with his uncle, Constantine. They've gone down to the dock. The palace has its own dock. They've rushed down to the dock. They grab an Imperial yacht. I love it that they have yachts. They have Imperial yachts.
I know. And then they head off in this yacht. But it's obviously not an ocean going yacht because they can only go so far. So actually they just go down. They don't even really get out of the city. They dock by the Studios Monastery, which is near the city walls, and they get out and they go to find sanctuary in the monastery. Now in the meantime, the rioters have got hold of Zoe. She's been brought back from the island, shaving her head, which is sad.
They've also dug out her sister, Theodora, who's been in a nunnery for eight years. She's been in a nunnery for ages. Willingly or? No, I think slightly unwillingly. Yeah, okay. So they dug her out. They've got the two of them and they say, right, we want you to rule as co-empresses. Let's just get rid of this Michael bloke.
We hate him. So what to do with him? A load of rioters and Varangian guards break into this monastery, totally ignoring all the stuff about sanctuary. They drag him and his uncle outside. Now at this point I have to say Michael, who's behaved poorly I think throughout, he completely shames himself. He does not react as a Viking would react. A Viking would meet his death with a quip and a poem. So how would you react in this situation? With a quip and a poem. I've already told react in this situation? With a quip and a poem.
I've already told you. Yes, I think I would. Okay. There's no doubt in my mind. I hope the opportunity doesn't come about for me to hold you to that. Well, if I'm ever taking sanctuary in a monastery in present day Istanbul and rioters and Scandinavians drag me out, I hope I don't do what he does, which is he clings to the altar, sobbing like a baby.
Then he clings to the pillars, weeping, praying to God and worse saying, it was all my uncle's fault. I never wanted to do it. That's the, that's the, that's low. I would do that. That would be me. So they take him outside. They hold him down. This is a bit that younger listeners will very much enjoy.
He's screaming and shouting and they gouge out his eyes. So the point of doing that is if you're mutilated, you can't continue to be emperor. Right, as with kings. So it's what Godwin has done to Alfred back in England, gouging out the eyes. As with that, there's always the risk that you may end up killing the person you blinded. Well, risk, is that a risk or is that an added bonus, Tom? Well, yes, I suppose. So this does make me wonder more about Harald Hardrada.
The sagas say the person who does the eye gouging is Harald. He's the person who did it. So this is in King Harald's saga. It's a scald called Theodolf. He wrote this, the warrior who fed the wolves ripped out both the eyes of the emperor of the Greeks. The warrior-king of Norway marked his cruel revenge on the Emperor of the East." And Snorri the chronicler, writing two centuries later, he says,
In these songs and many others, it is said that Harold himself blinded the Greek Emperor, and they would surely have named some Duke-Ccount or other great man if they had not known this to be the true account. And King Harold himself and other men who were with him spread this account." So the historical method in operation there. So there is the historical method at the heart of the Icelandic sagas. Men said it, numerous sources, we've sifted the sources, and it's very clear that Harold Hardrada did this gouging. So you may well say, all's well that ends well. Michael, Seans eyes, he dies of his wounds a few months later. There may also have been some castration involved, the sources differ on that.
I don't know if Harold was also responsible for that. Let's say he was. So he didn't write a poem about that? No, he didn't write that. He scattered the genitals far. Yeah. If listeners want to send in their own poems, I wonder what that poem would be like. Harry in for the Ravens. Address them please to Tom Holland, courtesy of Goalhanger. Zoe and Theodora reign briefly as co-empresses,
and then Zoe marries a nobleman and he becomes Constantine the Ninth. Now clearly the Varangians have really benefited from this. They regain their old position at the top of the tree. Harold is their commander. We're told that a lot of gold changes hands, so Michael Sellers. The revenues budgeted for the military were set aside for the use of others, a cluster of sycophants and those who were appointed to guard the empresses. So that's Harold, Harold and the Varangian guards. So things appear to have worked out brilliantly for him. He's now very rich, is more powerful than ever. He's the right hand of the Empress, a
genuine player in the politics of Europe's most glittering empire. All looks good. And then, Tom, one day he is woken by a ferocious hammering on his door. When he opens it, he sees guards outside and their faces are cold. And admirers of Dominic's Adventures in Time series will know that when guards with cold faces appear on the scene, excitement is bound to follow. A giant snake is never far away. And so adventure will follow in the second part of this super soreaway episode. We'll see you then. This episode is brought to you by FX's Dying for Sex on Disney+. Based on the podcast of
the same name, Dying for Sex tells the+. Based on the podcast of the same name, Dying for Sex tells the story of Molly, who is diagnosed with stage four breast cancer. Determined to feel everything she can before she can't feel anything, she decides to leave her unhappy marriage to explore her sexuality, with some encouragement from her best friend, Nikki.
FX's Dying for Sex, streaming April 4th, only on Disney Plus. Sign up now at DisneyPlus.com. Are you crushing your bills? Defeating your monthly payments. Sounds like you're at the top of your financial game. Rise to it with the BMO Eclipse Rise Visa Card. The credit card that rewards your good financial habits.
Unpoints for paying your credit card bill rewards your good financial habits. Earn points for paying your credit card bill in full and on time every month. Level up from bill payer to reward slayer. Terms and conditions apply. Let's drive good together with Bonterra and Volkswagen. Buy any sustainably focused Bonterra bathroom tissue, paper towel or facial tissue and you could win a 2025 Volkswagen all-electric ID buzz. See in store for details. Bonterra for a better planet. No purchase necessary. Terms and conditions apply. See online for details. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. So Dominic, cold-faced guards have intruded on Harold, absolute cliffhanger. What's going on?
Well, this is a good point to stop and ask ourselves how true any of this story is. So as we said in the first episode, any biography of Harold Hardrada has to rely on these very colourful sagas that have three massive problems. Number one, they're written down centuries later. Number two, they often wildly contradict each other and the stuff in Constantinople is often incredibly confused and contradictory. And number three, as we've said before, many of the elements of them are clearly fantastical. So for the stuff we would have been describing, you describing, effectively what biographers of Harold are doing is trying to stitch together a plausible narrative out of disparate elements in the
sagas. And that is assuming that any of it might be true. That any of it, but we know that some of it clearly is true because of the, for example, the stuff about Auraltes. Right, but his involvement in what was clearly a very celebrated episode. If he's your hero, you would want to intrude him into something like that. I mean, it would be like, you know, kind of flash man or something. Yeah.
The eye gouging. There's a bit of a flash man quality, isn't it? So Harold, I'll try it in his life. Slightly. So there are three elements that we haven't fitted in that appear in the sagas that historians and biographers have sort of grappled with. Number one, at some point Harold is imprisoned, possibly by Zoe. Number two, there is some kind of love affair, possibly with Zoe, but probably
not, probably with an aristocrat called Maria. And number three, there is a death-defying escape by ship from Constantinople. And they could be completely made up, but they might not be. Can I just ask Dominic, I mean, the key thing for Harold has been to get gold. Yes. And so the question hanging over all of this, if there is, you know, he doesn't get locked up and escapes and makes a death defying escape on a ship, as we will explore, where is his gold?
How is he getting his gold out? Has he sent it back already or what is happening there? The answer to that is very straightforward. He has already been sending it back because we are told in the sagas quote, all the gold he had sent ahead from Constantinople, a treasure hoard so immense that no one in Northern Europe could recall ever seeing so much wealth in one man's possession and sent ahead to Kiev, to Yaroslav, to his prospective father-in-law. And he may say, well, why didn't Yaroslav just steal it?
The answer is, if he's gonna get it anyway as a bride price for his daughter, Elisif, he doesn't need to steal it. And also, clearly, Harold isn't the kind of person you want to get on the wrong side of. So to return to these three elements that we haven't fitted in, different historians and different biographers
propose different combinations. There's a really fun one in the most recent biography of Harold Hardrada, which is a book called The Last Viking by the American writer Don Holway and it kind of makes some sense so let's go with that. The sagas say Zoe had always had a great fondness for Harold. There is this I think probably made up story that at one point she said to him I'd love a lock of your fair hair and he said her, Let us make an even trade of it, Majesty, you give me one of your nether hairs." So very Lord Byron behaviour. Very Lord Byron. I don't believe if Rangin Guard would have
spoken like that to the Empress. It seems just very implausible. Anyway, maybe she did have a fondness for him, and clearly if he was involved in the counter coup against Michael V, she would owe him a debt and she would feel they had a relationship of some kind. Now King Harold's saga says, at this point he falls in love. There was a young and beautiful girl called Maria, brother's daughter of the Empress Zoe, and Harold asked for her hand in marriage but the Empress gave him refusal. The Varangians then in Constantinople have told people here in the north that it was said by well-informed
people that the Empress Zoe herself wanted Harold for her husband, although another reason was given out to the public. So what's going on here? There actually is a woman called Maria hanging around at the court at this time. She's not Zoe's niece, but she is her husband, Constantine's niece. It's like the beginning of a very bad play. And what is more, she is Constantine's mistress. So this person does definitely exist.
Maria Sclerina. In looks says Michael Sellers, Sclerina was nothing special, but by her character and wits, she could charm a heart of stone. Her voice was musical. In conversation, she had a natural lilt, an indescribable style of telling a story. At any rate, says the chronicler, she certainly bewitched me. You know, that is a passage entirely left from Plutarch's Life of Cleopatra. I mean, Life of Antony.
Exactly. That's the interesting thing about it. It's a portrait. She's not great looking, but her voice is musical. She can speak all these different tongues. She has it when she tells a story, all of this kind of thing. So again, a literary formula within a source. Anyway, she exists. We know that she was Constantine's mistress. They conducted their affair very openly. Is it possible that Harold also carried on with her? I would say personally, very unlikely. But the sagas do insist, different sagas insist that he had taken a fancy to somebody called Maria and that Zoe didn't like it. So this is another saga called the Morkin's Ginner. Nordbricht and Maria continued their affair and at this time, Empress Zoe
developed a burning hatred for Nordbricht. Remember that was his alias. So eventually, if the sagas had been believed, Zoe snapped. She accused him of being familiar with the maiden Maria. The emperor had Nordbrok seized and bound and taken to a dungeon. The King Harold saga has great fun with this. The prison was on high open topped tower with the cell door at street level. Harold was shoved through this door together with Haldor and Ulf. So that's Legolas and Gimli.
Legolas and Gimli. So Aragorn, Legolas and Gimli are in this flipping prison. It's dark, it's damp, it's full of bodies, just like you'd want a Tolkien-esque prison to be. And Haldor is in the cell because he's given this excellent line. He says, it's not brilliant, but I suppose it could be worse. And then it does turn out worse. And then they see the snake rises from the water. There was a huge venomous serpent that slept by the stream trickling through the cell. The serpent fed on the corpses of men who crossed the emperor or his lords and was subsequently thrown down there.
That's the Morkinskinner saga. So some sagas say a serpent, some say a dragon. I mean, it is possible there was a snake in this prison and that it existed. Of course, it's more likely if this is all a mad, it's going to bear wolf-style fantasy. Anyway, in the sagas, as you described in that beautiful reading, Tom, Harold gets a stick and finally he manages to jab the stick in this snake's mouth and then stabs it in the heart with a knife. This kind of Lord of the Rings style action. Now if you think that's bonkers and a bit implausible, what then happens, he has a vision.
His dead brother Olaf, he's been off the stage for a while but he's back. He appears to Harold in a vision and says, look, links look bleak for you, but don't worry, I will get you out. They stay in this prison for two nights and then they hear a woman's voice at the door, would you like to be rescued? And she says, I'm a noble woman. She never gives her name. She always wears a hood and is kind of very mysterious.
When they say, well, who are you? She says, your brother, King Olaf appeared to me in a dream and told me to come and rescue you. And she lowers a rope to them. She and her servants haul them up up this rope and then a massive game of Thrones scene. They run through the night back to the Varangian barracks. They get their weapons. They wake their mates back into the night through the darkness down to the harbor. They get down to the harbor. They seize two galleys. They row out into the golden horn and then a total disaster. The golden horn is blocked as it always was by a huge chain, a barrier chain,
sealing it off from the Bosphorus. And so Harold comes up with a brilliant scheme. He says, listen, everybody piled down to the back of the galley. So weigh it down. So it kind of, your mighty weight is a great weight. Well, if they're 10 feet tall, all of these people, and Gimli's a dwarf, isn't he? Jump up and down. They weigh these boats down. So they're, they're angled out of the water.
And then they sort of like, I don't know, like Roger Moore and the man with the golden gun or something, they're able to kind of rock over the chain. Harold Hardrata's eyebrow is going even higher than it normally is. Exactly. And definitely he likes a quip, you know, so there must be some, I wish I could think of some Roger Moore style quip that he makes. You'll never chain me up again. I don't know.
Who knows? Anyway, they get out, one boat breaks up, a lot of the people drown, but they manage to haul the others onto their Harold's boat. Great cheers. As day breaks over the Bocerus, they turn north towards the black sea and safety. Unbelievable. They have escaped. What an amazing scene.
And the question that may be in some listeners' minds, has the rest of this history degenerated into mad fan fiction? And the answer is probably yes. I would guess there are some elements of this, a feud at court, an internal power struggle, Harold wanting to get the remainder of his gold out of Constantinople. Will you mentioned this book, which I haven't read, Don Holloway, The Last Viking. What is his suggestion? He just loves this story and tells it in great detail.
I mean, does he have some perspective on? Well, I think he says it's, you know, it's possible that there was some, that there was a dragon, not the giant snake, but there could be an internal feud. Zoe is, you know, she's, I think it's fair to say quite high maintenance. And, you know, there's a lot of politics. She has got a new husband who maybe resents the influence of the Varangian commander. Okay. Maybe Harold says, I want to go now.
I've had enough. And they say, we don't want you to go. You're the head of the guard. You know, what do you want you to go back to Norway for? Okay. Anyway, he gets away. Yeah. There's an alternative explanation, which is there is going to be another Kievan
Rus attack on Constantinople in the next few years. Yes. Cause Yaroslav sends that, doesn't he? Yaroslav sends one. So there is an alternative explanation, which is he leaves because he's had word get out because we're planning to attack and there may be vengeance against Varangians in the city, which is again, plausible. The truth of the matter, Tom, we don't know.
We just don't know. Yeah. What we do know is that probably by about 1043, he gets back to Kyiv. It's 10 years now since he went. He is 28 years old. He's an extremely rich man. He has enough money for the bride price. Elisipha is now 19.
So that age gap that was a bit preposterous 10 years ago looks slightly less alarming now that she's 19 years old. The fame of his deeds, which obviously are massively amplified by the time that Snorrius Dulleson sits down to write them up, but even at this point, presumably his renown is percolating northwards from Constantinople, do you think? I think definitely. I think Commander of the Varangian Guard, at that point, the most celebrated military unit probably in the Christian world. And the Roman Emperor's Guard, you know, that's not nothing. That's a serious thing. He's very well established. He's obviously got loads of contacts. He is, it makes complete sense that Yaroslav would be very keen to
marry him to his daughter, because you know what, if he does get back with all his gold to Scandinavia and gets his throne back, he could be a useful ally in the kind of geopolitics of the Northern world. But also the fact that he has made it in Constantinople, presumably also people are kind of, you know, people who know him are proud of that. Yeah, of course. It's like a kind of local striker going to some massively glamorous overseas club and then coming back kind of garlanded with awards.
Exactly right. Here's a man who you want to know. Here's a celebrity. Here's a man who will have no problem raising recruits. Because to serve with him. Of course, and there's that as well. Yeah. So they're married, probably in the Cathedral of St. Sophia in Kiev.
According almost certainly to the Orthodox rites, there's a lot of smashing of glasses and binding of hands and kind of crowns and stuff. But the thing that's interesting about Harald is you might think that all the glamour is in the South and all the money is in the South, but actually the Norwegian side of him clearly matters enormously. He's desperate to get back to Norway to reclaim what he sees as his throne and to avenge his brother. So Snorri Sturluson in his description of the marriage says he gained a princess, not to mention a hoard of treasure. And that's always kind of uppermost and that sounds quite authentic.
Yeah, I think so, absolutely. But he wants the treasure for a reason. And that's always kind of uppermost and that sounds quite authentic. Yeah, I think so. Absolutely. But he wants the treasure for a reason. And the reason is, you know, the crown matters a lot to him. Now in the 15 years, 15 years that he's been away, because remember he left as a teenager, a lot has changed. And this takes us back to the, away from the realm of fantasy to the realm of history. Cnut, his brother's great rival, is dead.
He's been dead for 10 years and his North Sea empire has fallen apart. England is now ruled by Edward the Confessor. Norway is ruled by Harold's nephew Magnus, the illegitimate son of his late brother Olaf. And Denmark is sort of trying to break away from the Norwegian kingdom. There's an interminable war between Norway and Denmark. And the guy in Denmark is a Jarl called Svein, who is Knut's nephew.
So it's still a family kind of row, really, isn't it? And one of the things that's always thought was intriguing is that Ellis, if so, Harold Hardrada's wife, one of her sisters has married Edward the exile, who is the half brother of Edward the confessor. So even England is part of this snarl of even Scandinavian matrimonial alliances. I mean, it's so odd, isn't it? Theo and Tabby were telling me about a series called Vikings Valhalla, which I've never seen, which has some of this in it.
Oh really? But I think this should be like a much bigger budget and more exciting thing. Cause I think all of this stuff is, this makes Game of Thrones look kind of footling and trivial. So, just on the North, Norway and Denmark have been locked in this long running struggle, Magnus in Norway, Svein in Denmark. So just on the North, Norway and Denmark have been locked in this long running struggle. Magnus in Norway, Svein in Denmark. And for Harald, this offers an opportunity, but also a threat.
If he can get back to Scandinavia quickly, he can profit from this and become a third player and profit from the uncertainty. But if he waits too long and Magnus of Norway wins and rules both then it'll be much harder for him to get a foothold. So perhaps early 1045, late 1044, hard to say. Around about this time he makes his move and he goes north and we do know that in about 1045 he arrives in Sweden in a place called Sigduna and there he receives very bad news. Magnus has got the upper hand, he's left it too late. Magnus has been crowned king of both Norway and Denmark and Svein has
agreed to be his Jarl, he's basically his deputy in Denmark. Now Magnus is a serious player. He's half English, always a good sign. His mother was an English slave and he'd become King of Norway at the age of just 11, but he proved really good at it. He was brilliant at winning support. He's actually incredibly skillful politician and he got this nickname, Magnus the Good. And this is in part, not just because it's not because he's kind. Yeah. He's good at politics.
He was well-spoken and quick to make up his mind, noble in character, most generous, a great and valiant warrior, says the Heimskringler Sagas. So Harold has got all this cash, but he's the underdog. And they finally meet uncle and nephew in Skåne, which was then in Denmark and now is, of course, in southern Sweden, that autumn, 1045. And the sagas describe how Magnus is there with his fleet and he sees this ship coming from the east with gilded dragon's head, covered in gold and jewels. And this huge messenger, in this story, in 1066 generally, there are always these messengers
who actually turn out not to be, the sort of mouth of Sauron who turn out to be Sauron. This messenger comes and says to Magnus, would your uncle Harald be welcome? And Magnus says, yeah, sure. And then the messenger says, I am uncle Harald. Good fooling. And Harald says, yeah, hello nephew. How would you like to divide the kingdom between us? Not really.
Well, we're told Magnus gave his uncle a friendly answer saying he would take the advice of his chieftains and the wishes of his subjects. He gives him a diplomatic answer. I said he was good at politics and they part on quite good terms, but it's I mean, it's pretty obvious to Harold that Magnus is going to give him nothing. So Harold sends a messenger to this bloke Svein in Denmark and says, let's restart that war. Let's divide Norway and Denmark between us.
Now Magnus, he doesn't fancy the war starting again because Norway is not a rich country. You know, it doesn't have many towns and markets. It doesn't have especially rich farmland. I mean, that's one reason they've got involved in the whole Viking business. But Dominic, it is rich in giant men with double axes. It is, but they require payment. And he struggles, it's a big problem for Norwegian kings to raise tax because they don't really have the same infrastructure as somewhere like England. So Magnus thinks, I can't compete with all this gold, I just don't fancy a war.
So eventually he sends a message to Harold and he says, look, actually, I will share the kingdom if you will share your gold. And Harold thinks, well, fair enough, because I don't really have many Norwegian contacts and it would be a massive hassle fighting this war. So they have this meeting, this very entertaining meeting to share the gold. Harold makes a huge display of all the gold. He gets a huge ox hide and he pours all the chests out, massive piles of gold. Harold makes a huge display of all the gold. He gets a huge ox hide and he pours all the chests out, massive piles of gold, and he says very loudly, I have travelled
to many lands and taken many risks in order to earn all this gold. And then they're going to get their men to weigh and divide all the gold equally, but the point is they've both got to put in what they've got. And he says, nephew, what gold have you got to add to all this? And Magnus says, oh well, I've actually spent all my money on these wars. I've got one thing which is a golden arm ring, one ring, and he puts it in. Harold, this is not much for a king of two kingdoms, and some would say it is not rightfully yours. And Magnus says, my father Olaf gave it to me the last time I saw him. True, but only after he took it from my father for no good reason.
Massive tension in the air. Harold is dissing. He's dissing Olaf actually, his brother, and saying that Olaf had taken it from his own father Sigurd the sow. So everybody's very anxious about this and everybody says, oh, this clearly is not going to last. Like clearly at some point, Harold is going to turn on Magnus or vice versa. Well, one of them's going to go, but we never get to that point because you remember in the road to 1066 series. So the last couple of weeks, people were always dropping dead on expected convenient moments.
Yeah. Convenient points when their acting contracts had come through an end. Well in 1047 end of 1047 Magnus is off the coast of Denmark fighting Svein and he has a dream in which Olaf appears as father and Olaf says, look, you've got a choice. You can live to a ripe old age, but you will commit a crime that will damn you to hell. Or you can die young now and join me in the afterlife. And Magnus, I think foolishly says, well, I'll die young. I'd like to join you in the afterlife. Do you think that's foolish? I think that you don't know what the nature of the crime. I mean, I'd want to know more
about the crime, I think. But this is happening, what, a thousand years ago and he'd still be in hell now if he'd gone for that with no prospect of release. It's like those experiments they do on toddlers, you know, do you want instant gratification now or you get two cakes later? I'd probably take the cake now. I'd opt for death and heaven. Well, in that case, you would have exactly the same fate as Magnus. He wakes, immediately comes down with a fever and on the 25th of October 1047, he dies. And in one of the sagas, there's a lovely bedtime scene, deathbed scene, bedtime
scene, I mean, I suppose it is bedtime in a sense. Harold comes in to see Magnus. Oh, nephew, I see you're dying. And Magnus says, leave Denmark alone. I leave it to Spain. Let them go in peace. The Danes. Harold obviously has no intention of doing that. He's now one,
he's king of Norway. It's all he ever wanted. It's all he ever wanted. Everything has been the fighting the snakes, the gouging out of eyes. And do you know what? You've written these adventures in time books to inspire your young readers to follow their dreams. And Harold has followed his dream and now he's king of Norway. So there's a lesson there isn't there?
But you know what the real lesson is? It hasn't made him happy because his time as king of Norway is a little bit sad I think because it's basically 20 years of really boring war against the Danes in which nothing ever happens. Just constant raiding. And I imagine quite a lot of stuff involving cow buyers and that kind of thing. Yeah. Kind of burning people's cottages and stuff in a bad weather.
In a desultory way. Yeah. Really bad weather. He just fights for so long. He's got a massive warship. I mean, the best thing about it is this warship called the Great Serpent. I mean, Freud would love this. So Olaf Trigversen had had a ship called the long serpent, but Harold Hardrada and Sissner
had a ship called the great serpent. And he commands this ship. There's one battle, a battle at a place called Nisor, which is off Western Sweden between the Norwegians and the Danes. The Norwegians win, but they're all just miserable and cold and they both massive losses. No one's ever going to win this war. But the great serpent is still erect and proud. It is, but there's just a sense of joylessness to it at this point.
I think it's fair to say. So basically this war has gone on for what 15 years or something. And eventually Harold gives up his ambitions. It's fine. Swain can have Denmark, I've had enough. And all this has been very, very expensive. Swain can have Denmark, I've had enough. And all this has been very, very expensive.
Now during all this, Harold has clearly been trying to turn Norway into a more centralized, kind of nationalized tax paying kingdom, like, dare I say, England, or to some degree, I guess, in future Denmark. Or, more obviously, I'd have thought, um, Constantinople. Oh, Constantinople, which he's seen. Yeah, but it's going to be, look more like England, I suppose, in the long run, because he's also doing other modernizing things. He tries to develop a national queenage. And although he himself is clearly not a, you know, if he is pious, he's not,
definitely not a turning the other cheek kind of man. He does encourage Christianity and he brings in priests and monks from Kievan Rus, And of course, you can see why he would do that. He likes the idea of one god, one ruler, one church, state power. He's got his brother, hasn't he? Olaf, who is well on the way to becoming Saint Olaf, who gets enshrined in the great cathedral. And it's interesting, a lot of the kingdoms that are formed at about this point in time have patron saints who are from the
ruling family. Olaf is the paradigmatic example who are just massively, massively important to the regime because they give divine legitimacy to the dynasty. But it's a difficult process in Norway. I mean, Norway, the terrain isn't ideal for trying to impose a kind of a nationalizing regime. There's constant tension with the landowners in the north and in the center of Norway. It's not hanging out with glamorous born empresses, is it? It really is a bit miserable. And also I think there's an element of Harold is becoming possibly a little bit insufferable. Snorri Sturluson, who writes this very admiring biography of him in the saga, says,
King Harald was an absolute monarch, and the more secure he felt on the throne, the more imperious he became, so that hardly anyone dared to differ with him. And the big issue, as always, is money, is tax. He has been trying to raise taxes to pay for this incredibly boring war with the Danes. In 1064, the last full year of the war, the farmers of Norway's uplands basically refused to pay their taxes with tax revolts. So it's like he's turned into Keir Starmer. He's having to deal with angry farmers. Angry farmers, it's the same old story. Well, don't forget, angry farmers had killed his brother. Angry farmers and people in reindeer magic cloaks had killed his father.
We seem a long way now from magic reindeer cloaks. And I have to say, I have to say slightly the poorer for it. Yeah, we are the poorer for it. There's no doubt in my mind. Things have got worse. And this is the point at which they do. So 1065, when the war is over, Harold launched a savage harrying campaign against the uplanders that in some way actually anticipates William of Normandy's harrying camp.
I mean, this is what there's a definite similarity here that when you have kind of against the uplanders that in some way actually anticipates William of Norman's harrying company. I mean, this is what, there's a definite similarity here that when you have kind of, these are very, very ferocious, merciless monarchs who when they are challenged by provincial, perhaps more small-c conservative interests that are resisting the modernizing efforts of the monarchy, they react with lethal and terrifying force. Snorri Sturluson, the king ordered farmers seized, some of them maimed, others slain, and most of them robbed of everything they owned. The peasants pleaded for mercy, but his verdict came with fire. So again, advice and lesson there from history for Keir Starmer.
His scald, Theodolf. No scald can find words for the royal vengeance that left the op-lands ravaged and empty. King Harald's deeds will be remembered forever. And exactly that, as you said, Tom, this is the origin of the nickname Hardrada, which at school, I can remember being told it was hard ruler. It's kind of severe, isn't it? That's the translation now. Or even tyrannical or, I mean, some people might say robust. If you admire a strong leader, as I do, you would say robust, like our own greatest ruler in the 1650s. Anyway, that's by the by.
We've got to the end now of 1065. Harold is now probably 50 years old. Ellis Eaf has born him two daughters, but she has pretty much vanished from the sources. We know he has a second wife called Tora, who has had two sons, but we know virtually nothing else about her. I think there's a slight sense of Harold of, I don't know, ambitions unfulfilled or frustration. Yeah. It's a very powerful scene, isn't it?
And I guess it would require not just a great historian, but a great historian with an incredible command of the English language, fully to evoke the mingled glory and pathos of the scene. And I wonder Dominic, if you can think of such a writer and whether perhaps you have a passage of his prose to hand. Do you know, Tom, it's so, it's extraordinary that you asked that question because by a remarkable coincidence, I can think of such a person. Shall I read it? Yeah, why don't you? Because you, I think you'd give these readings the power and the majesty that they deserve. Yeah. And, and when I finish it, people can try and work at who they think wrote it.
Yeah. And maybe order the book. The golden sheen in his hair had long since faded and he could feel a stiffness creeping into his bones. Though Harold would never have admitted it. He seemed a figure out of time, waiting for the end. Sometimes he wondered if he would ever again know the thrill of adventure, the joy of battle. And then one cloudless day, a ship rounded the
headland and turned into the fjord. And Dominic, that author is of course yourself, your thrilling book about the Vikings available from all good bookshops. And we know it's a cloudless day. We know this ship has rounded the headland and turned into the fjord. And I think it's fair to say that with that ship and the advent of the year 1066, everything will change, won't it? It will change, Tom.
So to give people a little preview of what is coming, 1066 is upon us. And next week we will begin our climactic series on the epic events of that year. The death in England of Edward the Confessor and the accession of Harold Godwinson. Harold Hardrada invades England and the great showdown at Stanford Bridge. And then the invasion of William of Normandy, and the battle to end all battles at Hastings. And Tom, there's some amazing news, isn't there, for members of the Rest is History Club.
Would you like to share that news with them? Yeah, incredible news. You'll never have heard anything like it before, ever, while listening to this podcast. But just to break it to you, if you'll remember, you will hear all four episodes immediately and Dominic, more stunning news that again will come as a total revelation to listeners that if you're not a member of the Rest is History Club, there is a website where you can sign up and that is therestishistory.com. It's what Harald Hardrada would have wanted, isn't it?
Yeah, it is. I mean, he would definitely be, he'd be one of the elite Varangian guard of the rest of the History Club. Of that, there is no doubt. All right, on that bombshell, we'll return next time with 1066. Goodbye. Bye bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.